frau schwesig sie haben heute eine
kabinettssitzung zum thema saisonende
urlaubs ende mit den meisten
bundesländern gehabt was haben sie heute
beschlossen
ja schöne grüße aus mecklenburg
vorpommern aus schwerin
wir haben heute eine positive bilanz
gezogen für unsere tourismussaison wir
sind ja urlaubsland nummer 1 2 millionen
touristen waren bei uns seitdem shutdown
und wir haben in keinem bereich
irgendwie einen schweren infektionsfall
gehabt und jetzt gibt langsam die zahl
der übernachtungsgäste zurück ab
nächsten montag nächsten monat und wir
haben heute beschlossen dass es jetzt
auch möglich ist für alle anderen wieder
nach mecklenburg vorpommern zu reisen
also ob man als freund oder verwandter
leute besuchen will in mecklenburg
vorpommern oder einfach nur als
tagestourist das soll wieder ab vierten
september möglich sein
natürlich nicht für menschen die aus
risikogebieten kommen am donnerstag
werden sie zusammen mit den anderen
ministerpräsidenten mit frau merkel über
veränderungen reden die jetzt zum
saisonende zum urlaubs ende geregelt
werden sollen
welche erwartungen haben sie von diesem
treffen dieser sitzung also es gab er
zehn wochen lang gar kein gemeinsames
treffen deswegen finde ich es richtig
dass man jetzt sich auch mal wieder
zusammen geschaltet und ich bleibe bei
der linie die ich von anfang an
empfohlen habe
die großen themen müssen die
bundeseinheitlich regeln also welchen
abstand welche masken pflicht gerne auch
gleiche bußgelder oder auch vielleicht
einheitliche regeln bei
großveranstaltungen aber die detail
fragen wer kann wie viele leute zur
familienfeier einladen
so etwas sollte doch vor ort regionalen
entschieden werden denn die
infektionszahlen sind unterschiedlich
also brauchen wir auch unterschiedliche
regeln wir sind damit bisher in mv gut
durchgekommen
ein hauptthema ist aus meiner sicht dass
deutschland sich mit den fragen vom
internationalen reiseverkehr
doch ein bisschen übernommen hat wir
haben jetzt wieder viele internationale
reisen wir haben reise rückkehrer aus
risikogebieten manche fahren in den
urlaub
und kommen dann aus einem risikogebiet
zurück und dafür gibt es keine
stringente bundeseinheitliches strategie
und das ist das hauptthema finde ich was
frau merkel und herr sparen jetzt auch
mit uns gemeinsam beantworten müssen
dass das in zukunft besser läuft der
plan ist hier das quarantäne jetzt im
prinzip verlängert werden soll man also
frühestens nach fünf tagen einen test
machen kann der ein aus der quarantäne
entlässt sie hatten vorher schon ein
anderes regime in mecklenburg vorpommern
anderen umgang wie war das bei ihnen aus
bisher
wir haben in mecklenburg vorpommern
entschieden sehr frühzeitig das wenn man
aus einem risikogebiet zurück kommt es
nicht ausreicht dass man ein test macht
und dann kann man wieder arbeiten gehen
oder die kinder vielleicht in die schule
sondern wir sagen ganz klar wer aus
einem risikogebiet kommt muss in
quarantäne und muss zwischen dem fünften
und siebten tag einen test machen erst
dann kann er aus der quarantäne
entlassen werden weil wir die erfahrung
gemacht haben dass der erste test gar
nicht sicher ist
das heißt bei ihnen ist schon seit
längerer zeit dieser zweite test
notwendig wie kam es dass der rest der
republik abgesehen von schleswig
holstein nicht auch zu diesem ergebnis
kam schon früher kam das ist eine gute
frage das zeigt das eigentlich bei
solchen fragen der bund viel besser
steuern musste und wie gesagt sich nicht
um detailfragen von familienfeiern
kümmern sollte denn hier geht es ja auch
eine nationale frage und wir haben sehr
früh als bundesland bereits vor einigen
wochen dem bund mitgeteilt dass wir
einen einmaligen test am anfang nicht
für ausreichend finden dass wir damit
auch schlechte erfahrungen gemacht haben
und dass wir raten zu diesem test
zwischen den fünften und siebten tag ich
bin eigentlich ziemlich klar in diesen
reise fragen
wir müssen den menschen reinen wein
einschenken das internationale reisen
birgt noch weiter risiken wenn man in
einem urlaubsland fährt kann man nicht
mal sicher sein dass es nicht bei der
rückreise risikogebiet ist deswegen rate
ich der bevölkerung in mv er auch solche
reisen zu verzichten
und wenn man reisen macht dann bitte
nicht bewusst in ein risikogebiet und
ich finde wer dann doch in ein
risikogebiet reist sehenden auges musst
zurückkommen in quarantäne bleiben und
kann sich dann gerne auf eigene kosten
zwischen den fünften und siebenten tag
frei testen